[Music]
my design team worked through the night
to transform Milford Pennsylvania's
River Rock Inn and now it's time to
reveal the changes to Ken and his team
boy how are we good Seth how you feeling
great great
excellent all of you this week have
really put so much effort in to get this
in back on track so I'm greatly
appreciative for your efforts it's only
fitting okay that we star the relaunch
with a proper sign take a look at this
it's not the old side from the old
restaurant
it's a beautiful sign Rimrock inn and
restaurant the best food and lodging and
the Purple's how cool is that it's very
cool does it rise beautiful is wonderful
thank you okay
ready to go inside we are excited let's
go come through are you ready
it's a beautiful place to live and stay
not a place you've got to come and die
first off we have a stunning color on
the walls Don is that hideous paper so
now it's in keeping with a rustic charm
and all the bugs are gone too the
changes are just incredible I'm a bit
overwhelmed by them and blown away
totally blown away we replace that
dinosaur TV with a new flat screen guess
what it works okay replacing the
mattresses stunning linen oh my goodness
new table lamps and guess what gone are
the spunk stains Karen the Oni Milky Way
from the skies above yes Karen what do
you think I think it's absolutely
beautiful it's still a country end but
it's a country end of the year 2012 let
me show you the room next door please
this is incredible this is just amazing
Gordon just did wonders here oh by the
way what I've updated your router
okay so you have Wi-Fi you're blown away
worn away accent oh please come in come
in come in come in when I first arrived
the check II was so confusing
now the guests come in they sit down
we offer them a coffee glass of water
and then we'll go to actually booking
them in online how cool is that now how
much you spend on linen a month a
fortune a fortune
underneath tablecloths you had these
stunning natural tables which were just
being hidden at a ridiculous expense
focus on the linen upstairs in the room
before Gordon was here I just had a
restaurant now I have an end I have a
destination I can't wait I'm looking
forward to the relaunch tonight we're
gonna have a lot of fun you like this
yeah
whether new decor and Ramesh's expert
training don't care along with a newly
inspired cancer see ya enjoy your dinner
the river rock is in a much better place
time to go when I got here Ken
honestly my guy was a hopeless innkeeper
almost like someone had given up but you
know we've turned him around there's
almost like he's sort of he's got his
mojo back
and now river rock has every chance of
succeeding I tell you what I've seen a
lot of skies but not quite a Milky Way
like that
[ __ ] me as I prepare to leave guests are
arriving for the relaunch and I noticed
some familiar faces from the bar last
night and as promised they've brought a
friend
how are you my darling
first impression
I can feel a good night coming on
[Music]
Joey I need three onion soups three fish
cakes and fish finger with Ken trusting
his staff and not micromanaging he's
able to spend more time on the floor
leaving time to charm the Milford
Milford and this is I was excited to see
them she was very pretty
I look forward to talking with her there
we go ladies ladies thank you very much
[Music]
the inn is buzzing and Ken has invited
some very special guests to see the
place at its best and this is my brother
oh hello wise good to see you too and my
mother hello madam how are you hey well
thank you nice to meet you it's no words
to express how proud are you about
together upstairs
the guests are loving the new rooms and
downstairs they're loving the fresh
local menu that chef Stephanie
before I can leave there's one last
thing I need to take care of every
cellular please
why not for me if I can come on amazing
I listen thank you so much for coming
tonight not really sure thank you
Kent come here now I know feeling I feel
wonderful honestly at the beam of the
week I thought you're gonna sort of
almost I suppose fall to the wayside
where you bounce back and I'm grateful
for that thank you I'm grateful yeah oh
and one more thing you can't have a
better wingman and Gordon Ramsay oh
please yeah he gave me your number it's
in my pocket and I'm most thinking oh
it's nothing
let them do it yeah thank you so much
Gordon made me realize that I should be
less of the hands-on owner who can't see
the forest through the trees from here
on I'm empowering my staff to make their
own decisions and I'm gonna support them
no more micromanaging for me
what a week what a galaxy